[Music]  there are people believe this world is  Farington  it's all lollipops and rainbows we don't  do lollipops and rainbows we know those  are pretty colors that just hide what  the world really is black and white sumo  shout save us we will whisper  we convinced ourselves that they were  gone but they were just hibernating the  game for everybody oh please coordinated  simultaneous attacks at the homes of  Tulsa PD until the cops hide their faces  and now the bad guys don't know where  they live and who doesn't want a secret  identity people who wear masks are  dangerous we should be scared of them  because they're hiding something  Laurie Blake FBI you know he could tell  the difference between a masked cop and  a vigilante no me neither  near the vast and insidious conspiracy  at play towards youth our  [Music]  who are you maybe yeah I'm comin in  he lives on [ __ ] Mars you curse too  much  [Music]  oh [ __ ]  [Music]  nothing  I only just forgot  [Music]  [Music]  you